en Guyane et à Mayotte nous avons ce
défi que l'immigration clandestine et
malheureusement les femmes et les
enfants sont souvent victimes des pires
atrocités sur les routes migratoires ces
enfants reçoivent un accompagnement
notamment lorsqu'ils sont parcours de
scolarisation mais ce n'est pas
suffisant et cela contribue fortement à
l'échec scolaire aussi j'aimerais savoir
si la Croix Rouge a des préconisations
afin d'accompagner ses parents étrangers
sur l'accompagnement des parents
étrangers
en Guyane
mais pas qu'en Guyane sur
c'est le cas aussi en Martinique parce
que nous avons c'est vrai que la
difficulté que j'ai c'est que j'ai pas
présenté notre dispositifs
d'accompagnement des demandeurs d'asile
par exemple que Madame la signatrice
connaît bien en Guyane maison nous en
avons aussi en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique et en tout
cas Mayotte la Croix-Rouge n'est pas
agréée pour accompagner les demandeurs
d'asile donc nous nous avons des
dispositifs de lutte contre
l'illettrisme en fait
la force de la Croix Rouge et aussi
d'avoir des bénévoles qui vont faire du
de l'accompagnement scolaire de la lutte
contre l'illinitrice de la formation en
langue étrangère
j'ai oublié mais ça va revenir le flux
voilà et c'est ce travail est fait au
sein de dispositifs c'est-à-dire que on
les bénévoles vont organiser des temps
d'échanges avec les personnes en
situation irrégulière nous proposons
également nous avons des dispositifs
fortés par les bénévoles de
vestiboutiques ce sont des lieux où nous
avons des vêtements
certes de seconde main mais pas que
parce que nous avons des dons aussi de
boutiques qui nous donnent des vêtements
et donc nous proposons à des tarifs
parce que il est important pour nous
mais je veux dire ça va être 50 centimes
1 € de zéro et pour ces personnes c'est
aussi important de participer donc nous
avons des vestiboutiques sur une
majorité des territoires et
l'accompagnement se fait aussi au
travers des centres de santé comme comme
je le disais donc sans différenciation
de de
public et comme vous le savez madame la
sénatrice en Guyane nous avons la charge
de la seule plateforme d'aide
alimentaire de Guyane en fait il n'y a
pas de banque alimentaire en Guyane
c'est comme un Mayotte c'est la
Croix-Rouge qui joue ce rôle et comme je
l'ai insisté ce cette porte d'entrée est
vraiment importante pour nous pour
travailler avec les familles